recent war news
in ukraine
instead of bringing relief and hope it
attests instead to new atrocities such as the
massacre of good and
increasingly horrendous cruelties
carried out even against civilians unarmed women and
children
are
victims whose innocent blood cries out to
heaven and
begs if he will end this war
let the weapons be silenced
let us stop sowing death and
destruction
let us pray together on this yesterday
this flag was brought to me right from my mouth
[Music]
[Applause]
this flag comes from the war
just from that tortured funny city
and there are
some children here too  ukrainians
accompanying us
we salute ii and pray together with
them
[Applause]
here come come here
comes this part too all
these children had to flee
and get to a healthy land
this is one of the fruits of the war let's not
forget them and let's not forget the
ukrainian people
[  Applause]
[Music]